How did I get Hysteria?
Am I gonna go to heaven
like Uncle Buster?
No.
But it is believed
that female sex moisture
turns venomous if not released
through regular climax.
What?
Oh, no.
I haven't climaxed
since horseback riding lessons
when I was a girl.
No one worry.
Pater Freud is here.
Now, Blanche, please,
stimulate Beatrice
with a feather,
lightly at first.
Um...
Oh, [bleep],
[bleep], [bleep]!
Yeah, yeah, uh-huh,
uh-huh, [bleep]!
[Beatrice moaning]
Ah!
Hmm.
[Beatrice sighs]
Did you already orgasm?
Is that where I get
the quiver-shakes,
and I'm transported to a ghost
purgatory on a beam of light
and then I ask for forgiveness?
I've never seen this before.
Blanche, continue.
Let's see if Beatrice
has multi-orgasms.
Ah!
Yeah.
[moaning, screaming]
Mm.
Well, I'd say you're cured.
I will treat this patient
myself.
[device buzzing]
[grunts]
Now, pelvic contractions
will release pent-up
uterine energies
which have been
affecting your moods.
If you want to improve
my mood,
you're gonna need to use
another finger.
Now, Dodo, in some elderly
specimens such as yourself,
a more strident course
of stimulation is required.
Servant, begin.
[bike whirring]
Faster, Garfield,
faster!
Faster, faster!
[women moaning]